what is going on everybody welcome to
another flask with Python tutorial video
in this video what we're gonna be
talking about is the marriage of flask
with PayPal so heading on over to
developer bat paypal.com you'll be
greeted with a page something like this
if you're visiting at any time now or in
the near future that you're watching
there this video was posted the home
page here is this V dot 0 so not too
long ago paypal acquired a company
called Braintree which brings the total
number of major ways that you can accept
paypal on a website two three so you can
use something like V dot zero which is
the latest offering from Braintree you
could use the legacy PayPal API or you
could use the good old fashioned IP n
that's what we're going to be using but
I feel like since they put this huge
thing on here I'll just tell you what it
is anyways the idea of Braintree is it's
gonna let you accept credit cards PayPal
Apple pay Bitcoin this kind of thing
okay and legacy PayPal API basically
both of these are kind of really the
Braintree API it's going to allow you to
accept payments without actually looking
like you're using PayPal so it makes
your company business look like you
actually have a payment processing
segment so so you can kind of never
break the immersion of your website
whereas right now generally all you can
do is throw a little banner or maybe at
the top of the PayPal checkout or
something like that now for us you know
I just me personally just wanted a nice
simple way to integrate PayPal I wanted
to accept paypal and credit cards so the
way that you can do that really simply
is with the IP n so on developer.com
sign up make an account this is separate
from your PayPal account generally I if
I recall right you log in with your
PayPal account but you still need to
sign up and set up some stuff once
you're signed in you might even get away
with using your PayPal account I might
be totally wrong anyway once you're
signed up go to your
- bored when you're in your dashboard
you'll probably not have an app already
created so go ahead and create an
application from there you'll head to
the sandbox accounts and just kind of
take note you've got a business and a
personal account here just note that
they're there they should be there by
default if not go ahead and create the
account one for business one for
personal the personal is the actual
buyer right this is the person that's in
theory gonna buy your your product and
then this this is the business that's
selling so the sandbox is as it sounds
it's this nice little sandbox
environment which if you're not familiar
generally we use this term it's like a
nice secluded and safe area to do
development okay so the PayPal sandbox
is actually pretty nifty so if you head
to sandbox PayPal calm you should be
greeted with a page that looks identical
to PayPal right this looks just like
PayPal and you can log in and stuff like
that but you can only log in with
sandbox accounts so by that same token
if someone puts a button or a payment
whatever on their website that actually
goes to sandbox top PayPal calm you can
log in with your sandbox account play
with play money because these these
accounts are generally given about ten
thousand dollars in their account this
one has ninety five ninety four so
almost ninety six hundred dollars so
that's the idea of the sandbox so you
can develop and you can test but if
everything else working as it should and
then when you're ready to go live you
change sandbox PayPal calm in two
locations and you change the payer or
the payer and piggy
I guess I don't know which one you would
choose the payer or payee because payee
is paying utter you change the business
email anyways we can have a
philosophical debate about whether it's
pay or pay II anyway I'm still wondering
okay so move on so so let's set that
aside and we're gonna start building the
flask back-end to do this now just like
all the other tutorials there's a
text-based version of this tutorial and
there's kind of a large degree of code
here so we're not going to spend a lot
of time writing out all this code
it is a lot of code instead I think well
we're gonna take the code from the text
based version and I'm gonna just explain
to you what that code is if we typed all
this out it would be like a 2-hour
tutorial so that's really silly so so
instead I'll just save you from reading
my lovely typos infected paragraphs and
you can hear my my my words instead so
the first thing that we're gonna go
ahead and do is well we need basically
three URL paths that we needed to fine
the first path is going to be a purchase
page this is somewhere the user can go
and make a purchase okay second page and
arguably you could have a third and
fourth but the second page is a success
page so when the user actually
finalizes and completes the transaction
where do you want to send them when
they're all done there is alternatively
a third type that's like the success
only this is the failure page this is
where the user cancelled the transaction
somewhere along the way generally I just
send them back to the home page screw
them right send them to meet spinners
anyway yeah that's a good idea
so so arguably you can do that generally
I just send them to the home page though
and then the final one is really the
crux of all this and this is your IP n
handler so the IP n handler is what is
going to handle these IP n IP n stands
for instant payment notification if
you've ever had an actual PayPal account
you receive payments stuff like this IP
n is basically exactly what you get in
your email so when someone sends you a
payment if someone if you refund a
payment if someone creates a payment
plan or profile with you if someone
cancels that if someone's late on their
payments stuff like that so so that's
what the IP n does to is and you can
direct those notifications to a specific
URL and then from there you can handle
that and you can also probably the
biggest thing is actually verifying that
it was indeed PayPal that sent you this
information so let's go ahead and get
started first we'll go ahead and go to
the
you know our home app directory and
we'll go into our init dot pi file and
at the top of this file we are gonna
need to make a couple of imports might
as well make them while we're here the
the two major imports are going to be
from work cert we're gonna need to
import these immutable dictionary and
then we also want to import requests I
don't see that we're already importing
requests so I'm just gonna copy and
paste in there again text version of
this tutorial in the description so go
there you can probably find this
otherwise type it out if you want we're
gonna use a mutable order dict
we'll talk about that when we get there
actually but just just input and bring
that in and basically if if you know
dictionaries in Python are not ordered
okay so an immutable ordered dictionary
means we can't change it and it is
ordered okay and then requests to make
requests so now we're going to go to our
typical development zone which is a near
Jinja man and we're gonna start throwing
in some stuff again I'm gonna take this
from the text-based version of this
tutorial and paste this is the success
page this is the path to it we need to
still create success dot HTML but we'll
get there basically this is just where
the user is gonna go when they complete
the transaction so now we'll go into
templates and we need a success dot HTML
so new and we'll call the success HTML
take a sip of water and we'll copy that
information in boom no problem we sent
that in not close out of this for now
and then we're going to let's go ahead
and make the other one I kind of didn't
order it this way but I thought I didn't
it let's see we had the success and then
I wanted to have the purchase page
where's my purchase page there it is
okay so we've got success and this is
for the the actual purchase page
and this one loads a subscribe data HTML
so let's go ahead and make that this is
gonna be a subscription button and this
code will require a little more
explanation so the success page was just
a you know simple stuff you should
really know what everything that's going
on there
subscribe page a little different okay
so what's happening in our subscribe
page is the following first we're
looking to see if the users logged in if
they're not logged in they have to log
in so we can gather some user
information on them that way when they
pay we know who is paying so we ask if
they're logged in if they're not we just
slap in a little message that says hey
you need to be logged in in order to
make a subscription now we have a form
here and the form has an action we're
calling it to PayPal the action is to go
and send this data to sandbox stop
paypal.com cgi-bin web square and it
posts this information subsequently and
posts all this information so mostly
this information is information I've
taken directly from PayPal there's a
PayPal API page that has all of the
variables that you need here you can
also generate an A button and then view
the HTML for that button and just take
all that because basically this is to
create your own button because the
PayPal buttons are ugly they look pretty
unprofessional they don't ever like go
seamlessly with a website so this is our
way of making a wrong button so most of
these values are values that are just
coming straight from from PayPal's API
that explains all of these values now
even the custom the custom is something
you can send in custom to PayPal so the
value for that custom value there for us
is just going to be that session
username otherwise the only other really
important thing here is ten dollars okay
and then these this is the return so
this is the page that the go to on
success this is the pages they go to on
failure and this notify URL actually is
probably
the most important this tells PayPal
where to notify about the these instant
payment notifications finally this is
just a subscribe submit button this is
something that the user can actually
click this is the only thing that's not
hidden about all this entire form and
input so so when we go live the things
that we would change would be this this
is sandbox type paypal.com
that would be changed to just PayPal we
would change this email to our email so
we get the money for real not our
sandbox again and really everything else
stays the same the one thing I would say
is when you do these little hidden
inputs there are ways for people to do
this entire form but change this number
to a penny
they can do that so you always want to
check how much that person actually paid
you because they can they can change
that number and that's no good okay okay
so you should be ok with that now and
that shouldn't be too too much more
confusing there is an API somewhere that
gives off like all of these values and
the different ones that you can use I
don't have a link to that right now but
I'll put a link to that in the tech
space tutorial if and when I find it
I've seen it at one point long ago
generally when I want to make a button
though I just go to PayPal generate a
button and you can view the HTML for
that button and it looks pretty much
just like this and then I kind of modify
the HTML from there but there is an API
somewhere with all these little secret
values and what they mean because like a
3 how would you have any idea that meant
like how much the user is gonna pay
anyway so that's our subscribe and now
we're gonna get to the the ipn part so
the IP an actually doesn't have its own
dim template it doesn't need one so
we're done with with that for now and
let's take the IP encode so I'm gonna
copy and paste this IP n function it's
actually quite a bit of code but a lot
of it is logging and exception handling
and stuff like that so it's actually not
as
challenging as it may appear so paste
okay so here's our IP n function simple
enough it's gotten a Peru IP n the only
method we're accepting here is post and
what's happening here is first we have
an empty arg then we're taking the req
we're just setting the request parameter
storage class as an Amitabh alors der
Dix the reason why we do that is because
dictionaries are not ordered and what
happens and the way this works is we get
a post from hopefully PayPal but we
don't know who is making the post we get
a post of all of this kind of data right
it's the transaction ID the payer e-mail
the date the amount the gross all this
stuff we get this data but right now we
don't know who it came from okay so we
get all this data and we take that data
we have the and we need to retain the
order of that data and then what we do
is we rebuild our own request and we
start with our validating URL so this
will be the second location for the
sandbox PayPal switch that you'll need
to make before you go live validate URL
and then we add our arguments to that
URL so basically what we get this
request we get all this data okay we
take that data and we throw it right
back at PayPal and we're like hey did
you just send this to us and then PayPal
will respond and say either invalid or
verified okay so if they respond and
they say yep that's that that was us
then we're like okay great thanks and we
go along now just because it came from
PayPal does not mean that that data is
safe secure or accurate okay things can
still be modified so when we go and we
look at things can be changed like the
username right remember that was a
custom value we sent we chose that value
and some other stuff can be changed like
the transaction ID that's coming
directly from PayPal
so that's almost certain to be legit
whatever that is but a lot of this stuff
can be changed and for a great example
would be the payment gross the user
someone who is not just your regular
user can go in and they can modify the
request that they're about to make and
they could say they're gonna pay you a
penny okay and if you're not if your
program doesn't check to make sure the
gross payment was not actually the value
that you were supposed to get PayPal
doesn't have any way to protect you
against that so keep that in mind so so
you'll want to check the payment gross
and probably check the fee to just make
sure no funny business was played there
all this information is supplied by the
IP n we're grabbing our own date the IP
n will send you a date or like a time
but I go off server times so I'm gonna
use the serve time now a couple things
to keep in mind see we're using thwart
everywhere
I just just any time if you don't know
if you don't remember thoughts is an
escape string okay so thou'rt is not
going to stop you from ever getting
hacked but it's always a good idea to go
ahead and escape everything you put into
your database that you allow a user to
generate in any way ok users cannot be
trusted they will try to break your
stuff so so just just every time you put
stuff into a database unless it's like a
totally back-end operation you should be
escaping it so so if it's verified great
grab this data if we for whatever reason
that operation goes south we're going to
go ahead and open up a temporary in the
temporary directory an IP n out text
file we're gonna save this little data
string to the file write it cool we're
done now if this operation is fine we're
gonna go ahead and open up the IP n out
we're gonna say that that was a
successful IP n ping so we're gonna
write success to that file we're gonna
write the data good to go
finally we're gonna go ahead and
establish a connection to our database
we're gonna insert into our IP n table
which doesn't exist yet
we'll make it we're gonna insert all of
this data that we just grabbed the UNIX
the payment that user name the last name
payment garage blah blah you get a bunch
of information and we'll hopefully I'll
remember we'll check the IP n out text
file and you'll just you'll see how much
information comes it's a lot of info so
we insert that commit clothes clothes
and collect the garbage now this else is
corresponding to any other return other
than verified okay so if that's not if
that's the case then we return failure
just notice that the string is slightly
different so failure success error with
the IP n data just make it something
unique ish so you know you're doing you
could get official with your logging -
we're not even there is an actual
logging module we're just this is just
meant to be a really short just if
something doesn't log we want to be able
to go check the log file and see what's
going on so that's everything okay so so
again what's gonna happen someone's
gonna go to the well actually let's
let's go ahead and go through the
process and we'll talk our way through
what's happening in the code and what's
happening in to the user so we've done
that we've got the init dot pi cool I'm
gonna close that for now
well we'll probably have to open it back
up unless everything goes really well oh
the other thing we need to do is we need
to go into my sequel and when you make
that IP n table so let's go ahead and
pop into my sequel to do that it's my
sequel - - user equals root - P enter
your password for the database and once
you're in use Python programming or
whatever if you chose a different name
for your database what we want to do is
we want to create this new table IP n
again this is a pretty long query we
have a lot of columns so I'm gonna just
gonna copy and paste the query that is
from the text-based version s tutorial
so we're creating the table IP n we've
got we're tracking the unix time the
payment date bubble blah blah blah you
could have the auto increment ID if you
wanted I really don't see any point
that because you're gonna have a unique
transaction ID that PayPal generates for
you so if you want to do the whole you
know some people are really anal about
that first column has to be that auto
incrementing key so if you want to do
that go for it but I think it's a waste
okay so we ran that query cool let's go
ahead and describe ipn just to make sure
the table looks like what we expected
sure enough no problem that looks good
so we're done in my seat well we'll
leave my sequel up I don't think we have
to actually do anything else no we need
to restart Apache so we'll do that and
now we're probably good to go unless our
website doesn't load for whatever reason
so let's load up our website looks good
I think your page was purchase so we'll
head to purchase right we need to be
logged in to subscribe we're not logged
in let's go ahead and log in well hello
there
okay heading back to purchase awesome
we're logged in let's subscribe we've
route okay
so right now it's putting in my actual
paypal email so we don't want that so
we're gonna log in to that yeah the
Harrison - buyer so we are on sandbox
paypal.com so use your sandbox PayPal if
you if you tried to use your real paypal
wouldn't work anyways and then put in
whatever your password was if you forgot
what your password was you can go to the
sandbox let's see if I can get there if
I'm not kicked out already
you go there profile let's see if it
didn't kick me out awesome
so you can go there and if you forgot
the password just go to change password
and you just change the password it does
not matter so just keep that in mind so
let's move that aside now okay so we're
good to go we're gonna log in we've got
this subscription stuff like that cool a
green pay good okay so now we can return
to the test facilitators store and great
it says thanks for your purchase alright
so and it gives us this nice auth token
that you could use should you
to use the all token now let us pull
back into our database and use Python
and let's see if this worked okay cool
so we're ipn did work we got the data
here let's see if we can fit it on one
screen almost so user unix this is our
payment date this is the user name of
the purchase last name spire the gross
was $10 fees 59 cents payment net nine
nine forty one the payment complete that
user had the money wasn't an e-check or
some other nonsense awesome
okay so we can quit out of here and
finally before we bring this to a
possible close we are going to head to
our temporary directory TMP IP an out
let's open that up and these are pride
from before i'm gonna move these aside
for us and this is basically all the
information that gets sent to you so
you'll notice that we didn't take all of
the data okay
so you've got transaction type
subscriber sign up you've got subscriber
ID you've got their last name the
resident country
I forget what MC and currency there's
there's two major ones one is how much
money in their currency versus how much
money your current see you actually got
and whichever one I'm using is the right
one so ever I had to look that up well
you get their pay or status you get this
this information here I think we already
left the token page though let's uh
let's run this one more time and check
that token there there you go pair
status there verified bubble blah blah
blah and you just you get all this
information right you get the receiver
information what period you get a lot of
information that kind of doesn't totally
matter but obviously if you're selling
like a lot of store items you might
you'd track like the item number stuff
like that and here's the subscriber date
that they also give you you get the idea
this is all the information the IP and
sends you back so you can use any of
this information that you want but you
definitely want to pay attention to the
amount so there we go now let's clear
the IP now let's save that because I
think you'll actually get to yo you'll
get two things from the IP n one of them
is going to result in a failure and I'll
explain why in our case that's resulting
in a failure so let's go back let's go
to make a purchase you can you can do
this a billion times if you want it
really does not matter so we'll
subscribe again and let me log into this
payers account and we'll a green pay
I'll actually show you another thing to
that's fairly important okay returning
to the store now let's refresh here okay
so the IPA now is updated no we got just
success maybe because it's not a new
profile generally what's gonna happen is
you'll probably wind up with two one's
gonna say success one's gonna say
failure and the reason why it's going to
happen is the IP n is gonna notify you
for two things that occur one is a new
automatic payment profile is set up but
this that might not be happening because
there might not be a new automatic
profile closely that measure and and
then another one is the actual payment
and if you look at what we're requiring
to grab from that dictionary we're
requiring some things that would not be
supplied here right
so this try is going to fail and you'll
get an error with IP n data because
something like you know payment net will
be there because it's just saying hey we
established a new payment profile okay
so so that'll be triggered and that'll
return an error and eventually you
really you're just gonna turn off this
anyways but just keep that in mind you
if you see that error I'm so I was kind
of surprised we're not seeing that error
because it should be the hair because in
theory we should have gotten to let's
try it oh there we go okay so we have
got a success in error and has success
apparently but you should see that it
when we go over here into our database
where it really meant I put the wrong
password use Python I mean now we should
have two columns because of the previous
one right there two rows rather that
we're storing the information right
again depending on what you're trying to
do with the API I guess things are going
to be a little different now the last
thing I want to show you guys is it's
fairly important if you ever find
yourself in a in a problem let me change
this let me see if I can just do it via
the sandbox rather than my actual PayPal
account I've logged into the wrong
PayPal account because you'll be on in
theory maybe a business account and let
me do and hopefully if this gets me in
I'll bring it back on the page I just
didn't want to bring up something I
didn't want to show okay so this is the
not quite it looks like they haven't
really updated and because they haven't
updated maybe I won't be able to show
you what I'm hoping to show you
generally you'd go to my profile and
then my set you'd actually on the
updated version it'll be my profile and
then settings and then you'll go to my
selling tools but this version isn't
quite updated with the most current
version of actual PayPal anyway you'll
come to this page and you should come
down to instant payment notifications
and you can come in to update and you
may need to turn this on
but you this will only stop you from
getting the IP N
- this URL inside the website but I'm
like 95% certain as long as it's in that
form that says what the IP n
notification URL is it's still gonna
notify to that URL so just keep that in
mind now so there's that you might want
to turn that on but really what's
interesting is this IP n history page so
you come here let's say for whatever
reason you push your thing live and for
whatever reason maybe maybe your
database gets corrupted you've got a
real Oh to backup or something okay and
your backup is missing the last 24 hours
of IP n data what you can do is you can
come here and you can load the last 24
hours
5 days for the last 14 days of IP n
information you can come here and then
you can say ok what I want to do is
maybe you don't care about the automatic
profiles like this is this is basically
an IP n notification sent about the
autumn like basically it doesn't have a
transaction ID
it means someone cancelled someone
started a new profile something like
that okay so you'd come through maybe in
in and maybe even if it was the last 24
hours and you wanted everything you
could come through here and you could
click this oh I thought we could yeah ok
click that and you can say resend ok so
this is going to resend all of that IP n
information now it says you can only
display up to a thousand but yeah you
can you can go like pages I think or
something anyway so if something like
that ever happened to you and you needed
some way to reach these IP n
notifications you totally can
okay so that's how you would do it now
these can take a little bit like this
might take five minutes before it even
starts updating I all redo this just in
case yeah it's gonna take a little bit
but once once it starts coming in it
would be like one two three four or five
so just because it doesn't update
immediately don't like start freaking
out it'll it'll come so
I think that's really all I wanted to
show you guys as far as the IPM was
concerned there's a lot of like little
stuff obviously don't forget that when
you go live basically you need to change
that sandbox paypal.com sandbox to
sandboxes one email address change those
and you're basically good to go the
other thing you would do is you would
truncate this table so yeah I'm
surprised we still don't have them yet
I'm gonna truncate it and then we're
gonna get all the IP end stuff but for
example like so you're developing and
what you would do is you would truncate
I always type I'm kind of bad when I
type my sequel right into console so
sorry I don't capitalize all the time
but you would truncate table ipn okay
and what that's gonna do is it'll stop
that table okay so now if we go to it'll
just empties it out
there's truncate and then there's delete
all delete all I think resets like any
special index so like if you did have a
self or auto incrementing key that would
restart whereas if you truncate you're
gonna not have I think it'll it'll start
back where it left off I might have them
flipped or something but if that matters
look into it I'm so surprised we're not
still we're not getting these these IP
ends resent maybe because I selected so
many they will come through though I've
been on the receiving end of waiting for
these reasons to come through but they
do okay so anyways that's it for now if
you guys have questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below obviously from here you have
to do your own handling so so like for
example on in the in it basically as
soon as you're content with let's go to
I piano when you're content with this
data and you check to make sure they
paid what they were supposed to pay and
if you have multiple item IDs you have
that too and if those two things line up
as they're supposed to
here is where you might issue some
updates maybe you start printing out a
shipping label of your shipping company
or something like that or it's a
subscription service here's where you
would run an up upgrade command right
now upgrade that user that way they're
upgraded almost immediately
okay so stuff like that so anyways
that's it for now
if again questions comments leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching